imagine you are part of the ukrainian
team negotiating with russia when russia
is attacking your country and killing
your people that's what rustom umarov is
doing he's a ukrainian mp and he's part
of the delegation holding peace talks
with russia he along with russian
billionaire roman abramovich suffered
symptoms of suspected poisoning earlier
this month after a meeting in kiev
i spoke to him earlier today from a
location he preferred not to disclose
mr umarov thank you so much for taking
time with us i know that ukraine wants
this war to end of course the whole
world does everyone wants peace but
after more than two months of an
invasion of terrible aggression attacks
on civilians there's still no sign of
peace so do you have hope
well uh we always have hope nevertheless
as you know from 24th of uh february
russia attacked us they
launched a full-scale war against us and
we
ought to
fight back
protect our cities our children
our women elders
and we also
wanted to show all the world that we are
able to
open up a channel's diplomatic channels
of
negotiations
we wanted
the world to know that
even though we are protecting the
european security the global security
we're able to negotiate for the peace
because we understand that
this war can bring
more bloodshed uh to the region so that
is why yes we are hopeful
uh but the decision on
to ending this war is in kremlin
yeah it's up to vladimir putin to end it
yes
how do you sit at a table and have peace
talks
with the russian side when so many
ukrainians are being killed
well as i told you this is uh extremely
hard
emotionally
physically
but because we know that if it will
continue it will kill more people
we
assume that we are a
wartime
peace and voice so that is why we have
to take it
into consideration that if we don't sit
we don't
negotiate we don't find a solution
it will continue
so that is why we have to take it
serious and
we take it as our
job so that is why it is physically and
mentally hard but we need to continue
is it possible to negotiate with a man
like vladimir putin i know you're not in
the room with him but he is most
definitely in charge
it is hard uh because
he tries to open up several verticals
which means that
legally when you negotiate with
on one topic
you constantly are fighting back in the
field
in addition uh he goes and fights you in
the media
so basically there are up to five six
different dimensions that you have to
fight
the decision is only in his head
so the only person who can stop this
bloodshed is vladimir putin
but at this stage as i said
every person who comes to negotiations
they have their own mandate
uh and
every person is mandated to negotiate
his own block
so at this stage it's hard but it
doesn't constitute that it's impossible
what is your mandate then
my job is to mediate uh to
architecturize
these negotiations
so that
they happen physically we don't stop
in being in contact with them
we have groups
that are represented by
ministry of defense general chiefs of
staff
minister of foreign affairs there are
humanitarian
issues but
this event of these negotiations we were
able to
evacuate up to 300 000 people from
six different regions 45 different
locations so
and now we're working on
possible evacuation
of people uh from mariupol so which
means that even though it's hard
but we save life so that's why we need
to be
continuing it
the evacuation from mariopol
particularly
difficult i know there have been so many
kind of
false starts if you like
hopes that it was going to happen
apparent agreements that fell apart
it is extremely hard to
agree on something with them why because
when
you negotiate you discuss different
categories of people children
wounded
women maybe kidnapped people
so uh when it comes to the
implementation there are always games
why because
they could
give you the
one checkpoint but they will be coming
to another checkpoint so there are many
peculiarities and
we take it seriously nevertheless we
understand that they don't keep promises
and that's why we sometimes ask the
international community international
partners to be able to
witness it why because they're twisting
the story in world media saying that
ukraine is responsible but i would like
to say that ukraine is trying to defend
its own territory
uh ukraine is trying to save as many
lives as possible so that is why we're
trying to evacuate
people wounded kidnapped
people that were
even children
just recently we brought back uh two
children that were forcibly taken to
a russian federation uh we know that
there are many
people killed and their
children forcibly taken to russian
federation but we're fighting for every
person and for
every part of our territory and for the
democracy so that is why we are
continuing these negotiations
you were one of the people i understand
it along with roman abramovich who had
symptoms of poisoning after one session
of peace talks can you tell me about
that and the effect it had on you
well i already
informed the media that i'm fine at the
moment but
it
happened maybe three four weeks ago
nevertheless uh my colleagues who are
more
into details whether it was a chemical
or
magnetic poisoning i'm not sure so
that's why i'm
not trying to tell more about it but
they're working on it
and soon i hope they will come up with a
result what was it
but at the moment i am fine and i'm
continuing
my job
can you help me understand or what your
understanding is of roman abramovich's
role in this he's one of russia's
richest oligarchs of course said to be
close to vladimir putin what is he doing
there
well uh he is
independent he is not part of the
russian delegation nevertheless he is a
mediator
he tries to mediate he tries since he is
not
from
[Music]
the state let's say affairs
so
sometimes there are issues that is hard
to discuss
so he goes to
the
russian part and discusses how we
perceive this issue
so
his role is mandated also
in
making
negotiations
continue
mainly he tries to focus on to the
humanitarian bloc
as i said like
those
kind of
exits or evacuation corridors
so
at this stage i cannot answer on behalf
of him but
he's involved in mediation as well
the west is of course providing more
lethal weapons more every day the
rhetoric too is ramping up the us
defense secretary says he wants russia
weakened russia's foreign minister says
the west is waging a proxy war against
russia and warns of provoking world war
iii
what do you read into all that and how
worried should the world be
well the world should definitely be
worried why because the war already
started so
every person who is not involved at this
stage should be
uh
should be thinking that it helps than
russia if it is not involved in
finishing the war on the
supply side we appreciate
canada's support for half a billion
support they provided and now they will
be providing uh some
apc's armored vehicles
we appreciate it
we appreciate canadian people for the
support
for the political and
diplomatic support that canada does
nevertheless world should be focused on
what ukraine needs in the fields
so when we talk a lot about potential
supply
uh it doesn't constitute that this
equipment has been brought to ukraine
has been brought to the fields to the
armed forces because uh we have uh
allegedly second largest uh army
fighting against us
and we don't have
uh
any equipment at this stage
to fight them back so that is why world
should be focusing whether we have it
rather than
potentially supplying it so if ukrainian
armed forces doesn't have it on the
field
it means that nothing is done
so at this stage what world could do is
to supply immediately
and bring it logistically to the fields
that could be a big support to us to our
armed forces and to our resistance
it sounds like you're telling me
promises have been made but not
necessarily not necessarily delivered on
well i would say that as a person who
is now
supervising some of the
issues related to this block
uh there are many uh
rules and regulations related to the
lethal and non-lethal supplies
uh
is it fortunate or unfortunate for
ukraine it's unfortunate because we need
it immediately but it has been regulated
a long time before us and to
get through these regulations it's very
hard because sometimes countries are
saying that we're able to supply but we
don't want to supply directly let's use
the third uh countries sometimes they
say
we can make a agreement but we cannot
make payment
sometimes they make payment but they
cannot make logistics directly so
basically speaking
uh most of the world is now concerned on
how they will be looking in
russian ice rather than supplying
ukrainian armed forces
with equipment
unfortunately unfortunately still many
countries are afraid
to supply directly to ukraine because
they will be in bad situation with
russian federation on diplomatic stance
or political stance and
is it a double standards i don't know
but
uh we're fighting not only for our own
independence but for the european and
global securities so we need the world
to know that
diplomacy and politics works until the
bombs
finished so at this stage we need to
fight back in the fields and we need
their support so they should not be
playing around
uh trying to
convince us that they will be in bad
situations with russia uh russians are
killing us so that is why
we want world to help us and bring the
equipment to the fields
is it do you think that canada has done
enough and has acted fast enough
canada is active uh canada is helping
diplomatically politically uh as i
already mentioned uh they already
supplied half a billion and they will be
supplying some apc's armament vehicles
nevertheless
the
speed is extremely important so we need
to supply as much equipment as we can
otherwise
this may uh
become a beginning of third world war it
is already
in progress but if we are
not going to defend ukraine it means
that
all the other countries
will be threatened by russia and we are
the only country at the moment able to
fight back
russian federation
this of course is not the first time
vladimir putin has invaded one of his
neighbors
it is hard to see any signs that he can
be trusted or that he's inclined to back
down or give anything up what are your
expectations of him
well our uh
major objective is to finish the war
by saving
all people
that we can
without
any risk to our territorial integrity
which means that we're going to fight
for our people for our territories for
democracy for the human rights
and it is our right to defend ourselves
so at this stage there is no much
of expectation but
what is happening now
every country should be re-evaluating
what it has done for the last 10 years
with this country because nowadays when
we see on our fields
tanks
aircrafts with so many
western parts supplied to russian
federation
and for the last eight years when the
world was saying don't supply defensive
weapons to
ukraine it makes us feel bad
so that is why we have to reevaluate
what is that what is being done now what
has been done before
to avoid this because today's bloodshed
has been taken the decisions has been
taken before so
my
concern is that there is no expectation
our major focus has to stop the war
and the world should be besides ukraine
helping to supply weapons helping
diplomatically politically and
financially with ukraine because as i
said we're not only fighting for our own
we are fighting for the democracy with
fighting for the human rights
and for the security for the global
security
mr omarov thank you so much for speaking
with us
and taking so much time and
we appreciate everything you're doing
thank you very much